Sau hãng không cú thể đã tạm dừng các đường bài đến vinh này giới là sau khi cuộc hàng không liên bão bị ý ếp à kẻng bãng quyết ở những gia tăng trong con phận nước này.
Chúc tất kìa phổi hàng không vinh này giới là người hay bà tối mục cho biết e-b area của tế bánh nhà, tắt a của buồn đồng nhà,
là tạm của Chile, abianca của Columbia và Gòn của Brasil đã đình chỉ khai thác.
Tật kìa là anh cũng thông bảo vý toàn bộ trên bây, trong gia đoạn hai mấy tư đến 20% thống mấy một.
Một số hàng như các bạn là mà, ấy rút và lất sân trà của tế bánh nhà vẫn duy tri hoàn đông.
Chúc đó, rồi trước hàng không bị cho biết, tình hình ảnh sấu đi cùng họ độ phôn xử ra tăng khiến mấy bây dân dụng bài qua cùng chời,
về nơi dây la sẽ đối mắt mình cơ mọi đối cáo hỏa đậu của hỏa chình, cất hạc kánh.
Cánh bảo đứa đưa ra dựa lúc tăng thẳng bị về nơi dây la cũng đang liều thang.
Theo thông tin từ bổng quan trức bị ý mà rõ tơ công bố nghe mà thông mấy một nhà trắng đang trở bị phá động chế dịch mới tại vì nơi dây la,
mong gồm các phương ăn hành động quân sự hỏng bán tuần sự biệt mất và khả năng liệt măng đảng,
cắt theo đều lúc số lẽ sở bảo vệnh sách tổ chức công bố.
Mì cũng hiện duy tri nhau tắt trên tổ sân bài gerat, a phố, tổ ngầm tần công, nhiều tổ chiến, tạm tiêm kích, a mấy lâm,
mấy mấy đồ bộ và mấy những bình sĩ trong khu vật quy mô trên thái gần xa như cầu của một trên dịch trong mắt tủy thông thường.
Lạm dưới lâu ngại Washington có thể đang sử dịch các bước đi mạnh tay nhận gây sự áp lên trên quyền tổng thống liệt của la s mà đưa lâu.
Rồi tờ cho biết, kích bản lất nổ bị lẽ gạo này có thể cũng đã được phía Mỹ thảo rõ.